keeping 190 tons of molten Zinc at 450
degrees Celsius in this Kettle cost 1500
pounds a day
dipping steel and iron components
galvanizes them against the elements but
the boss here could do with continued
government support to protect against
the corrosive impact of soaring Energy
prices we're having to have
conversations with our customers we're
trying to be as efficient as we can with
regards to the equipment that we use and
how we use it but ultimately we can't
absorb all of those costs and we're
having conversations with our clients
to ensure that we can pass that on but
that then becomes difficult for them
because it just falls down the chain
but those costs will rise further for
this business and thousands of others
after the chancellor told leaders energy
support is about to be cut
Jeremy Hunt told business groups and
trade associations meeting here that
subsidizing businesses energy bills has
already cost the taxpayer 18 billion
pounds and from April any support will
be less generous he offered no detail on
what comes next and sources say the
Prime Minister and the chancellor are
yet to decide exactly how much help to
offer but the bottom line is that even
with wholesale gas prices Finally
Falling business energy bills are about
to go up
he was frankly quite disappointing
meeting it still left a lot of
businesses in the dark so they have to
make an early decision the government
has to realize that prevaricating
has a price
the current support for business was
announced in October and runs for six
months to March it effectively capped
prices at 211 pounds per megawatt hour
for electricity and 75 pounds per
megawatt hour for gas which government
estimated would save a pub 3 100 pounds
a month and a school four thousand
pounds a month on its energy bills
that support could now be halved in the
spring and is likely to be Universal
rather than targeted fueling inflation
that's already pushed food prices a
record 13.3 percent higher in December
with fresh food up 15 in a year
State support for households will also
fall in April leaving consumers and
businesses more exposed to the energy
storm Paul Kelso Sky News